so the question was does conference form
have properties that map to these
properties in conference yes the
conference form has a name property the
user is going to enter the name of the
conference when they create a conference
and again it has a topics property
because the user is going to enter the
topics when they create the conference
but no conference form doesn't have a
property for profile key the profile key
is going to be calculated based on the
profile that's the ancestor of the
conference and also no it doesn't have a
month property because the user doesn't
enter the month they just enter a start
date and then the conference constructor
actually calculates the month based on
the start date